okay today I'm going to talk to you
about nuclear equations so what a
nuclear equation is is when an a
radioactive element undergoes nuclear
decay
it means the nucleus is breaking down
and different particles can be emitted
so different particles can be given off
during this decay so we need to know
about four different types of decay and
how to do the equation for each one so
to begin with we are going to look at
alpha decay so for each one if we know
the if we know what the particle is then
we could figure out the equation so an
alpha particle is like this it's made of
two protons and two neutrons
remember this bottom number the atomic
number also sometimes called the proton
number tells the number of protons this
top number the mass number tells us the
number of protons and neutrons so the
format of radioactive sort of nuclear
equations is always like this so let's
say we're trying to figure out the
equation for the alpha decay of radon so
we're given this now as long as we know
this particle we need to remember this
alpha alpha particle then we could
figure out the equation because there's
always a rule the rule is we start off
with our element that's decaying
breaking down and then we write the new
element that's been formed and the
particle that's there's been emitted
given off so we're going to come back to
figure out what this is in a second but
first of all I'm gonna write down my
alpha particle which is this now the
golden rule the way to get all of these
different equations to work is we must
remember that the total mass and atomic
numbers must be equal on both sides so
each time we're just thinking this
number here on top this mass number here
must add up to the sum of these two mass
numbers and the atomic number at the
bottom must add up to the sum of these
two atomic numbers so let's have a quick
look at radon so radon has got a topic
mass of two to six and the other part
have got four which means because we
lost four protons and neutrons it's now
down to two to two
the bottom one we started off at 88
we've lost two so therefore it must be
86 now we no longer have radon because
the proton number of checks the atomic
number has changed so what we need to do
to figure out what we now have is we
need to use a periodic table so here we
can see there's our radon with 88 but
we've lost two probably we've lost two
protons so we need to count back to
there's 86
we now have radon our end okay next up
we need to look at this which is beta
minus decay so a beta basically what
we're what we're giving off is this
thing here which is basically the
equivalent of an electron so again let's
imagine we had to do the equation the
nuclear equation for the radioactive
decay of this carbon isotope so again we
start off with carbon we show that it's
being broken down it's decaying I know
that I'm producing my beta minus
particle so now again just as before I
just need to make sure the top and the
bottom add up on both sides so 14 on the
top there's zero here so there must be
14 as well because 14 plus zero is 14
now on this side something plus minus 1
is 6 so that there is going to be a 7
because 7 plus minus 1 is 6 so again my
proton number has changed so I must have
a different element so I started off
with 6 and now has 7 so I have formed
nitrogen now in beta minus decay a
neutron changes into a proton and an
electron so that's why the mass number
doesn't change okay next up what I have
next is positron emission so what a
positron is
is it has the same mass as an electron
but it's just a positive particle rather
than a negative particle so let's
imagine I had the nuclear decay of this
fluorine isotope so it starts like this
again I show my arrow I know I need to
learn each of these particles because if
I do then I could figure out the rest of
the equation so for this one here on top
it's going to be 18 because 18 plus 0 is
18 on the bottom something plus 1 is 9
so it's going to be an 8 on the bottom
again my atomic number is changed so I'm
going to have a look on here what 8 is
it's oxygen so we formed an isotope of
oxygen so in B 2 minus decay a proton
changes into a neutron and a positron so
this is why the this is why the atomic
number decreases by 1 because it has one
less proton now finally the last one is
Neutron emission Neutron emission
remember emission just mean that
something is emitted it just means it's
given out so my Neutron is that remember
a neutron obviously has no protons and
has one Neutron so let's imagine if I
was doing the neutron emission of this
particular isotope of beryllium so so
when this beryllium decays it gives off
one Neutron so again I know that is my
Neutron so again the mass numbers need
to add up so something plus 1 is 13 so
on top it's going to be 12 on the bottom
something plus 0 is 4 so it's going to
be 4 in the bottom now this time because
I haven't lost any protons at all my
atomic number stays the same as a result
I still have beryllium it's just a
different isotope of beryllium so
remember the key to all of these is if
you know the particles if you can
remember these different particles then
you just need to make sure
the atomic sorry the mass numbers add up
on both sides of the equation and the
atomic numbers add up on both sides
equation the final thing that we need to
know is this because gamma rays can also
be given out during nuclear decay so
gamma rays don't change the mass of the
nucleus that's because if you remember a
gamma ray is simply a part of the
Elektro away from the electromagnetic
spectrum so it essentially has no mass
so when gamma ray is given off it's just
a way of getting rid of excess energy so
guys that's everything we need to know
about nuclear equations thank you